monsieur karoutchi merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
oui nous entend alors vous comptez donc
un saisir le conseil constitutionnel on
le disait notamment sur la question de
la responsabilité des élus
très concrètement quelles sont vos
craintes pour les élus c'est extrêmement
sommes d'ailleurs ça ne porte pas que
sur les élus locaux et les maires mais
aussi par exemple sur les autorités
organisatrices des transports publics
mais aussi directement ou indirectement
sur les directeurs d'école et les chefs
d'établissement pourquoi parce que par
définition c'est le gouvernement qui a
décidé des conditions du confinement et
c'est naturellement et c'est son rôle
exécutif qui décide des conditions du
déconfinement à partir de là si on dit
aux élus locaux si on dit au directeur
d'école il faut ré ouvrir les écoles les
établissements les collèges si on dit
aux organisateurs de transport
il faut remettre des métros des rer des
trains etc vous pouvez pas après dire à
ces gens s'ils ne commettent pas
d'erreurs
le 10 ans ils ne commettent pas
d'erreurs et s'ils remplissent toutes
les conditions sanitaires souhaitez vous
pouvez pas les laisser seuls en face
d'éventuels recours aux plaintes de
familles qui a et dira mais moi je suis
sûr que j'ai trapel commises dans le
métro ah mais moi je suis sûr que mon
fils ou ma fille a peut-être ulcos vie
dans l'établissement scolaire ou en tout
cas l'a transmis à ce départ en enlevant
de l'établissement scolaire
donc voyez bien ya un problème de
responsabilité pénale
l'état a décidé du confinement du
déconfinement dans les conditions qu'il
souhaite
il doit assumer du coup qui doit
endosser cette responsabilité pénale
dans ce contexte les membres du
gouvernement les membres du gouvernement
n'ont salle aux attentes
en revanche dans bien des cas dans bien
des situations
on prévient on prévoit par la loi quels
sont les critères de mise en
responsabilité ou des duos des
directeurs d'école ou des chefs
d'établissements ou d où des chefs
d'administration s'il y a
c'est à dire que la responsabilité peut
être mise en cause naturellement syli à
faute mais a à nous de savoir
naturellement définir ce que la faute
est ce que le fait de remplir les
engagements ce qui est le problème dans
le texte à la déclaration est dans le
texte qui suit immédiatement sur la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'est que le président de la
république le 23 avril s'étaient engagés
à inclure dans le texte
la définition la responsabilité des élus
aux des autorités organisatrices de
transport sur la possibilité de mettre
en cause être consultés seulement s'il y
avait faute ou négligence
ça n'apparaît pas dans le texte actuel
ce qui veut dire que en réalité et je le
vois bien
beaucoup de maires beaucoup d'autorités
organisatrices de transport j'ai vu un
communiqué sncf ratp organisateurs de
transport qui dit la tension ne nous
mettait pas dans des situations
intenables
nous avons besoin d'une définition de la
responsabilité par rapport aux
déconfinement l'état ne peut pas dire
alors que nous parlons nous demandons à
ce que le port du masque soit généralisé
sur la voie publique
l'état dit pour le moment non c'est un
transport public oui mais pas sur la
voie publique
bon tout simplement parce que pour le
moment il n'a pas apporté suffisamment
basses que nous avons des difficultés
mais vous comprenez c'est le
gouvernement c'est l'état qui décide des
conditions du déconfinement par
conséquent à tout le moins qu'il met en
place un système où la responsabilité ne
peut être engagée que sur une faute ou
une négligence mais pas de manière
générale alors plus généralement vous ne
dites ne pas être contraints ce
déconfinement mais vous avez des doutes
sur sa réussite il se situe où
aujourd'hui ses doutes de l'énoncé
d'abord le problème des masques on voit
bien que un certain nombre d'élus un
certain nombre de maires souhaitent que
la population dans la ville et pas
seulement dans les transports et des
masques d'ailleurs vous regardez un peu
partout à leval aura comme dans tous les
hauts de seine comme à nice comme à
marseille comme partout les mairies les
conseils départementaux commandes
organise la fabrication de masques de
textile à distribuer à la population
c'est bien que les élus sont conscients
que le port du masque est un élément
fort donc là dessus il ya un doute
pourquoi est ce que le gouvernement
continue de dire non le port du masque
n'est pas obligatoire sur la voie
publique
si tout le monde académie de médecine en
tête considère que le port du masque est
une bonne chose pour mettre un terme en
tout cas pour un ralentir l'épidémie
deuxième élément sur les tests le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que c'est
extraordinairement flouze que 10
gouvernement on nous dit pas de tester
au logis pour le moment ils sont pas sûr
il ya quelques jours nous disait y aura
des tests sérologiques bon donc ça a
changé
on nous dit qu'il y aura 700 mille tests
par semaine mais il ya encore huit jours
on en est et royalement à 250 mille
tests par semaine est ce que réellement
dès le 11 mai on arrivera à faire 700 fr
100 mille tonnes par jour en france si
oui tant mieux mais il faut pas nous
dire 700000 si au final il ya trois cent
mille quoi et de la même manière on nous
avait dit avec le tracking c'est à dire
le traçage des gens thorel connu voilà
les conditions là c'est plus flou on
revient en arrière on nous dit ce sera
volontaire ou à la sur la volonté même
du de celui qui aura contracté le
qu'ovide et non pas par un système de
traçage donc un peu moins de ce lot un
peu plus de certitudes dans une période
où les gens sont confinés où les gens
sont à pied légitimement vu le nombre de
malades
le nombre d'hospitalisations nombre de
décès bien entendu que les gens sont
inquiets ils ont besoin d'une parole
claire dubois clair un chemin clair de
déconfinement il ya des annonces et ne
nie pas depuis quelques jours mais nous
attendons du premier ministre demain et
dans les jours qui suivent les
précisions et à partir de là qu'on
puisse avancer mais pour le moment je
serais tenté de dire
tout ça est à la main de l'exécutif
c'est normal c'est son rôle c'est parole
du parlement d'organiser les
confinements mais en même temps c'est le
rôle du parlement de demander des
garanties à la fois sur la
responsabilité mais aussi sur les
conditions matérielles de déconfinement
merci beaucoup roger karoutchi on l'aura
bien compris - de foule ou plus de
précision je rappelle que vous êtes
sénateur les républicains à des
hauts-de-seine